teams that still should be salty
about a loss
all time any time in the nfl
something they should still be pissed
off sorry london about even today peter
go ahead take the first one hello london
uh mike i i i've got to take the saints
rams missed interference call in the nfc
championship game how can you not
call that that's that's like the worst
missed call
it made not in nfl history but certainly
in recent nfl history without any
question that's got to be number one
every time i look at this play i still
think
how possibly is anybody looking at that
and not calling it i just i still just
can't believe it
and the thing that still amazes me and
and even though it's against the rules
to do it i'm amazed that that al
riverand didn't exercise his prerogative
to yell at the referee someone needs to
drop a flag now because if you don't
we're gonna have a mess unlike any mess
we've ever had and they're still dealing
with how to clean up that mess properly
uh more than two years later i'm gonna
go with the tuck rule game
raiders fans still salty
raiders uh employees coaches players
anyone still there who has any tie back
to that team and obviously john gruden
back again as a head coach still upset
about it i'm told that at one point and
this lasted for a while back when they
actually used fax machines some of the
employees of the raiders organization
had a still frame of tom brady getting
hit by charles woodson at the top of the
cover page of every fax that they sent
out that's how upset the organization
still was about that call that robbed
them of a birth in the afc championship
in 2001.
hey look you talked to amy trash now
obviously it was al davis's right hand
person with the raiders he talked to amy
trask and
it takes her about six words to get her
blood boiling and the veins sticking out
of her neck and
you know the thing about raiders people
once you work for the raiders you learn
one thing from al davis
vengeance is ours
and you know because that's al always
operated that way so if you work for the
raiders you always felt like everybody's
out to get us
all right and and you know one last
thing about it they ultimately changed
that rule but they waited like a decade
to do it because they knew how obvious
it would have been if they changed that
rule in the aftermath so i think it was
like a 10 or 11 year statute of
limitations that expired before they
changed that we're all right peter round
two you're up
you know my favorite play just when i
start thinking about plays officials
screwed up is the fail mary game
and you know the seattle uh green bay
game
where in the end zone there is uh you
know a mugging and a and a and
a catch
and all this and
you know basically you just can't
believe that that this is how this game
really ended you know it's just hard to
believe that they call a touchdown for
it it wasn't a touchdown
but they called it a touchdown
and that moment ended the lockout of the
regular officials back in 2012. that
that three weeks it wasn't as big of a
disaster as people in the league office
feared it was going to be
but once that happened by thursday night
the regular officials were back on the
job and yeah because that was a monday
night game
yeah and it also you know and it's
impossible because you have to go back
and play the rest of the season but if
you just go apples to apples and you
take that loss and turn it into a win
for the packers i think they would have
had a buy
a home game in the playoffs you know
things may have gone differently for
them in the 2012 post season if that
loss had been a win next one for me i'll
go the dez cotted game from 2014 cowboys
and the packers i still think it was a
catch i think it was ruled a pr and i
know it was rude to catch on the field i
don't think there was enough even under
the prevailing definition of a catch at
the time to overturn the ruling on the
field with clear and obvious evidence or
indisputable visual evidence the
standard was at the time he's got the
ball he's got multiple feet down there's
that there's the ruling the official
comes over and says that's a catch
i don't think there's nearly enough to
say it wasn't peter and i if i'm a
cowboys fan i'm still upset about it
seven years later
yeah i don't blame you for being upset
because look at every step of the way on
this and i totally understand by virtue
of the rule when his hand hit the ground
the ball moved and all that but man he
had the ball in his hand for a long time
mike
that lunging that's the football move
that they always talked about that
wasn't codified the football move the
lunging of the ball multiple steps and
the lunging of the ball and the ruling
on the field as it's a catch and
there's not indisputable visual evidence
to overturn that ruling on the field all
right round three peter grop
mike
my favorite bad call of all time or
missed call or no call of all time
uh it has to be the snowplow game in new
england in 1982.
obviously you remember this you know it
was a snowy day in foxboro dolphins
against the patriots
and uh a guy on work release from a
local prison
waved out on the field because he had he
had the snowplow okay and a guy was
waved out on the field by patriots coach
ron meyer and on the other sideline don
shula is screaming you can't do that you
can't do that
but the snowplow comes on the field
clears a path
and john smith the kicker for the
patriots kicks the field goal that wins
the game and the dolphins lose i
remember don julie even late in his
career i'm serious this is the loss
he was most bitter at because he thought
it was the mo he thought it was the loss
that went against the spirit of every
rule
that the home team
cleared off a spot for its field goal
kicker uh which should not have happened
and so
i don't know it was it's hilarious to
watch and it's hilarious also to watch
and listen to don schule afterwards just
you know kind of go bat crap over it
after all these years it never really
occurred to me if you're going to do
something shady and you need someone to
actually do it pick the guy who's
already going back to prison anyway
why does he care
right now
yeah he's going back to jail anyway who
cares if he does something he shouldn't
have done all right well i think the
control room knows what my final pick
for this draft will be do i even need to
say it december 28
1975 i was 10 years old the vikings had
started that season 10-0 was their best
team of the 70s the game is over roger
staubach pumps left throws right
nate wright thrown to the ground by drew
pearson paul krauss knows it paul
krause's point to him he interfered the
officials were blind pearson threw the
ball out of the stadium one of the
officials got hit in the head with a
whiskey bottle
and uh there it is slow motion i really
don't need to see it again but peter
look i don't know anything about
technique for defensive backs in 1975
but diving forward as the ball is coming
in does not seem to be the acceptable
way to defend he was pushed he was
shoved and yes i am still salty about
that 45 years later
but mike you saw the flag come in
okay right after that play
what did the official rule on that flag
did he that wasn't a fly that wasn't a
flag somebody threw an orange
it wasn't a flag i've seen that zapruder
film many times like
i thought i remember when i was a kid
and i saw it i saw it flash across the
bottom of the screen i thought it was
too i was distraught and as i've said
many times before that was the low point
of my childhood and if that's the low
point of anyone's childhood it's not a
bad childhood if that's the worst thing
that happened to me hey mike from the
age of 1-18 how did you pretty good
how did you become a vikings fan
well i grew up in steelers territory and
everybody in the town that i lived in
was a steelers fan and the steelers were
good then and of course you had to be a
steelers fan and peter you've known me
long enough to know that the last thing
i'm going to do is what i'm supposed to
do so i rebelled against beelines being
a steelers fan i would have had a much
better childhood if i had been for super
bowl championships that would have been
nice but
you know it's just there there was just
something about the purple there was
something about you know the vikings
were good at the time so they were on tv
uh so you know i just kind of i i like
the color i like the helmet i like fran
tarkin and i love chuck foreman i love
john gilliam if you remember him number
42. and uh that was that and uh uh you
know i caught the virus and uh there
were many times i wish i hadn't
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports